so give me a viral moment you can force
that I'm gonna give you a list of names
good I could yeah yeah and tell me
whether or not
um you could genuinely take them or beat
them in a fight what kind of fight
um
MMA boxing just do just do just do
boxing boxing and we're I'm not gonna
follow any like weight class or anything
okay fine just in a street fight yeah
street fight no gloves but but street
fight but with parameters only boxing
[Laughter]
like no scratches what makes this no
scratching right here it's one of those
like the Kimbo Slice back okay okay
yeah bare knuckle but you can go to the
ground okay yeah you can go to the
ground so it is
no no grappling just bare knuckle so
it's like okay like they did like they
did your favorite show the one the
English people what the English people
back in the day
blinders
oh yeah
okay Nate Diaz
honestly now he killed me okay in a
boxing match in a backyard brawl with no
gloves on yeah
he's just a [ __ ] dog boxing match I
would win sanctioned boxing match in a
ring with gloves I would win uh-huh
backyard bro that's that's there's no
[ __ ] ideas Conor McGregor
boxing boxing I would win I would win
I'd beat Connor boxing backyard
I would have to go with him these guys
are yeah yeah Mike Bisping
is he the friend of the show is he the
British he's done our podcast twice oh
he's I like him I think he's old like I
think I could take him in the back here
Andrew Tate
I take him in a backyard bro too wow wow
I think yeah easy the guy plugs his nose
when he jumps in the water yeah I saw
you would [ __ ] kill me okay
oh Francis and ganu
he would he would turn me into paper
[Applause]
hey are you friends with him yeah
okay
um two more um Habib
no chance boxing boxing Habib maybe
Habib is a good boxer he's a good boxer
good I'm not sure I'm not sure I'm not
sure um Kamara Usman
he's so good too he's a great he's a
great Striker I think he would win so I
guess I shouldn't ask about Aleister
Overeem but no oh wait are you a fight
fan we're both big fat fight fans huge
you too you too yes I love it I love it
whoa I love YouTube how about this let's
go like lighter
I don't know it's tough bro I could do
this all day yeah yeah this all day
point is I [ __ ] up Joe Rogan
are you taking another fight boxing or
MMA I heard that you might do something
in the UFC huh
um
what's in the works out really when are
you announcing that we're gonna announce
that right here it's gonna be a uh
it's gonna be a 2023 thing maybe really
maybe in the UFC maybe maybe and it
would be great about that I will go oh
yeah